your body takes me to some kind of place
[Music]
Nick Jonas admits singing about sex with
his brothers can be a little weird it's
wild long gone are the Jonas Brothers
days of wearing Purity Rings you don't
necessarily like to talk about the
Purity rings in general and writing
about innocent young love I never
thought that I'd catch this
now they're all married dads singing
about more mature topics which can get a
little uncomfortable since you know
they're Brothers
a family affair in a new interview with
bustle the band spoke about how it feels
to sing about sex alongside one another
and Nick well he said it can be a little
strange if they're not careful about the
details you know it's part of the job
the brothers latest record the album is
out now and features a song called
Summer in the Hamptons
[Music]
Kevin Jonas who married his wife
Danielle in 2009 explains it's only
natural to speak about your life and
where you're at like that's my wife and
partner in crime you know this year will
be 15 years that we've been together and
then it'll be 13 years of marriage this
year Nick who's married to Priyanka
Chopra explained their approach to
performing more sensual songs we are
always conscious that we're Three
Brothers singing on stage together so
when we sing about sex specifically It's
gotta be kind of a nuanced thing and Joe
who wed Sophie Turner in 2019 clarified
that they're not duetting those songs
The Connection we have as a family still
is is really unique of course the band
burst onto the scene in 2006. Jonas
Brothers I'm Kevin
everybody in jail
[Music]
[Applause]
and they made headlines for wearing
Purity rings to promote abstinence until
marriage the band split up in 2013 for
six years but in 2011 Joe was the first
to sing about the sexier side of romance
on his solo album fast life
[Music]
you have to just be
true to yourself and true to the world
then Nick followed suit with his
self-titled debut solo album in 2014.
[Music]
I'm just excited about what I'm what I'm
doing on the music side of my own and
then in 2015 as part of the band dnce
Joe kicked things up a notch with their
breakout single cake by the ocean which
means well use your imagination
[Music]
for all of us as we get closer we spend
every second together but in 2019 the
guys got the band back together and have
been going strong ever since
your body takes me to some kind of place
[Music]
I think for us it was it was important
to step into this new chapter with a lot
of clarity about how we were going to
approach it and that was being as honest
as possible with each other and with our
fans
[Music]
thank you